ashlee fetters of GQ magazine wants to
thank President Barack Obama on
Wednesday she specifically expressed her
gratitude to Obama for giving her the
best sex of her life in a column titled
thanks Obama for four years in glorious
worry-free sex she praised Obama for
ending her fears of accidental pregnancy
here is her basic take quote look I
don't have to tell you how quickly the
fear of accidentally accidentally
getting someone pregnant
can kill your sex drive but you know
who's been out there for the last eight
years tirelessly waging a war on his
horrible
vulnera killing feeling of dread
President Obama if you've had sex with a
woman in the last four years and found
the encounter totally gloriously on
plagued by onst about the risk of
surprise fatherhood you probably owe
Berio a moment of gratitude see all
irresponsible people who somehow
disconnect sex with the risk of
pregnancy could have their
biologically-based fears alleviated by
simply tipping their hats so to speak to
the man who could cure it all
Barack Obama what gave Obama this
godlike power well he wanted everyone
else to pay for your contraceptives says
Fedders quote as a result the second
term of Obama's presidency and the year
2016 in particular is already being
called a golden age of birth control
team Obama also gifted you a golden era
of fun low-risk banging with your wife
your girlfriend or the friendly gal who
is nice enough to accompany you home
from the bar because surprise turns out
we're all more fun to have sex with when
we're not preoccupied with the worry of
not accidentally creating babies
actually it turns out speaking from
personal experience sex is actually kind
of fun even when you're trying to have
babies and it's not actually up to the
taxpayers to guarantee your level of fun
if you can only feel orgasmic if you're
not worried about baby-making here's the
suggestion pay for your own
contraceptives it turns out society
doesn't have much fun and much of an
interest in upping your game plus it
turns out contraceptives don't actually
protect you from the other risks
associated with picking up randos and
bars for a quickie according to the CDC
STD raise rates are arising again now
since death despite Obama's massive
coverage plan nearly half of all
pregnancies in 2011 were unintended the
rate of accidental pregnancy among poor
women was a hundred and twelve per 1000
quintupled the rate among middle class
women the accidental pregnancy rate
among black women was 79 per 1000 yes
accidental accidental pregnancy declined
generally in flight fashion and among
poor women more
substantially under President Obama but
accidental pregnancy among poor women
remain sky-high compared to the rest of
the population which suggests that
perhaps the big problem here is not
access to contraceptives but personal
sexual choices and the accidental
pregnancy rate should be noted has been
dropping steadily since the 1980s though
it did accelerate that drop under
President Obama but there's another
issue here too who in the world declared
that people have a right quota to have
sex enthusiastically and fearlessly
without concern about consequences on
the taxpayer dime it turns out sex often
has consequences
but those consequences can be mitigated
by a bit of personal responsibility we
are all capable of not putting that
there without that thing on it
contraceptives are cheap they are widely
available and believe it or not human
beings are not animals who must have sex
right now this very minute
rather than using some self-restraint
but according to Federer and much and
left without Obama we'd all be knocking
each other off at insane rates here's
what she says quote in other words some
55 million American women may have to
start choosing again between low-risk
sex with men and all the other myriad
out-of-pocket expenses of adult life
anxiety free sex or dinner on the table
anxiety free sex or the rent for many
women these could soon become everyday
trade-offs seriously really the average
rent in the United States as of 2013 was
about 1,200 bucks per month let's assume
the average woman in the United States
has sex a couple of times per week
that's probably on the upper end or
eight times per month you can currently
buy a thirty six pack of Trojans on
Amazon for under fourteen bucks so a
full year of contraception even if
you're using Trojans during the non
fertile period would be approximately 42
dollars realistically speaking very few
Americans are choosing between rent 1200
bucks a month and condoms under 40 cents
a pop when you worship government you
have to praise your God for his
benevolence and that means bowing before
the big man who ensures you never have
to worry about being punished with the
Bible I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
[Music]
all righty so we are going to get to
people trying to burn themselves to just
because Trump is going to be operated we
will be getting to Vladimir Putin doing
his best Donald Trump impersonation
really and all sorts of other goodies
but first we have to say thank you to
our friends over at tracker tracker is
the device that allows you to keep track
of all the things that you lose the coin
size device it locates misplaced keys
and wallets and bags and computers
anything in seconds you pair it to your
smartphone you attach it to anything you
can find a precise location with the tap
of a button also if you attach it to
your phone there's something in the
tracker that allows it to actually
override your silent the silent setting
on your phone so if you call your phone
from another phone it will ring through
if you call and the tracker is on the
phone which is super cool it's great for
me because my wife loses her phone
literally every day the tracker has been
one of the handiest devices that we have
and it has it has saved our marriage
because there's nothing more irritating
to me than spending 45 minutes looking
around for her phone before she
discovers it's exactly where she left it
in her purse trackers solves that
problem in about 10 seconds and right
now if you listen to the show you get a
free tracker Bravo with any order you go
to tracker comm the tracker comm th e
tracker commie enter promo code then and
if you get that if you do that you get a
free tracker Bravo with any order again
it makes losing things something you
don't have to worry about anymore the
tracker commenter promo clip end that
shows that we sent you and also it means
that that you're never going to lose
anything ever again
tracker comm slash bet and get that free
tracker Bravo with with your purchase
over at the tracker comm okay so the
Democrats are preparing for this
inauguration and the wailing and the
gnashing of teeth is a sight to behold I
mean it is utter madness if you'd
actually try to set himself on fire
apparently in front of Trump Tower the
other day but being a Democrat he even
failed at this so here is the dude
setting himself on fire
find myself on fire project as an asset
okay approaches we were protesting the
fact that we've elected somebody who's
completely incapable of respecting the
Constitution vo case you have to give it
to the protesters of Vietnam in Vietnam
particularly they actually set
themselves on fire successful this dude
couldnt even set himself on fire
successfully so Darwin nearly
accomplished his mission but apparently
when you're too stupid to actually set
yourself on fire successfully you tell
them take yourself out of the gene pool
so this dude tried to set himself on
fire but being a good leftist is
incapable of actually immersing himself
in fire easy of self-immolating his self
immolation was as much of a failure as
Hillary's campaign so well done there
sir other Luckies who are very upset
Snoop Dogg is very upset that he may not
be invited to white house to toke and so
he is a he's threatening any black
performer who performs at the
inauguration he's saying that he will
bring the the vast wealth of his rage
down upon there the nighted head hears
Snoop Dogg one of our great cultural
icons speaking about what he's going to
do to stop the Trump inauguration ain't
nobody gonna fall for Donald Trump Oh
which one you won't be the first one to
do it
oh wait I'm called roaster that one you
up with Tom for doing what's your Uncle
Tom to assert he's going around the
warners perform for me so not nothing
says racial unity quite like calling
people who want to give Trump a chance
and Uncle Tom and really I mean I can
see why Barack Obama invited two noob
dog to the White House so many times he
didn't sniff dogs at the White House
multiple times but I guess that means
that Snoop Dogg is now a political
commentator I'd like to see mark Lamont
Hill and Michael Eric Dyson talk about
why Snoop Dogg should shut up about
politics in school he doesn't know
anything or if they only reserved their
ire and scorn for Steve Harvey and Jim
Brown meanwhile actual top level
Democrats continue to say that they're
not going to legitimate the trump
presidency they're very very upset about
the Trump presidency w Wasserman Schultz
she says that she won't say that
legitimate president do you believe
Trump is a legitimate president what I
believe is that there's no question that
the outcome of this election was
affected by the Russian interference
with the campaign do you see a
legitimate president then or not I mean
is there is there a distinction between
those two things in your mind I'm not
going to use I'm not going to weigh in
on the application of the term
legitimate or not and if someone is
qualified to weigh in on whether
something is legitimate it is certainly
the woman who helps rig the primaries
against Bernie Sanders in favor of
Hillary Clinton and then had to resign
her post as head of the DNC because that
she clearly has a leg to stand on
talking about legitimacy she's not the
only one
Senate Minority Leader Chuck Schumer
from New York he says that he respects
all of the inauguration boycotters
because hey Trump isn't really a
legitimate so I respect wasn't coming
from I mean I think each person has to
make his or her choice choice on his own
but I don't begrudge those who have said
they were going to break up would you
urge Senate Democrats to attempt at each
person make his or her own decision I
mean he says that he's in his you know
order Senate Democrats they go to the
inauguration but none of the Senators
are actually boycotting because a lot of
them are vulnerable and the last thing
they want to do is tick off those voters
in the middle so there is Chuck Schumer
saying that this is illegitimate so the
Democrats have built up its entire big
narrative about how this election was
illegitimate because of Russian hacking
because of WikiLeaks sponsored by Russia
hacking the DNC and hacking John Podesta
emails and therefore this election is
illegitimate and Trump's an illegitimate
president well long comes Barack Obama
Barack Obama has because he's actually
capable set his own party on fire unlike
self-immolation die who couldn't even
set himself on fire successfully Barack
Obama didn't try to set himself on fire
he said all the other Democrats on fire
destroyed them down ballot destroyed
them in the house destroyed them in the
Senate 241 members of the Republican
House 52 members of the Republican
Senate 32 governorships owned by
Republicans Barack Obama lost Democrats
a thousand seats across the country and
on his way out the door he wants to
torch their only narrative too so their
narrative right now is that Trump is
totally illegitimate because the
russians hacked the election so
WikiLeaks are bad right I mean this is
what we've been hearing for the past few
months WikiLeaks are just the worst
thing in the world according to the left
WikiLeaks are now terrible because
WikiLeaks impact the election and
WikiLeaks are working hand in glove with
the Russians to help Donald Trump
so Barack Obama he comes along and his
last move in office hopefully it'll be
one of his last moves in office because
he still has 48 hours to screw things up
some more his last move is that he
pardons or doesn't party commutes the
sentence for Chelsea Manning who is the
traitor who handed a lot of the original
information to WikiLeaks including the
names of American soldiers including
confidential information about American
ops that put American lives in harm's
way including information that Osama bin
Laden himself said he found valuable
Chelsea Manning who was then private
first class Bradley Manning gave all
this information to WikiLeaks and Barack
Obama was the guy who was actually in
office when when Bradley Manning was put
in jail then of course Bradley Manning
decides that Bradley Manning is
transgender Bradley Manning believes
that he's a woman now and so he calls
himself Chelsea Manning so I called him
Chelsea Manning now because it is
possible in America and everywhere else
to change her name it is not possible to
change her sex so he's a man and his
name is Chelsea Manning if he wants to
be called Chelsea Manning just like
Caitlyn Jenner is a man who calls
himself Caitlyn Jenner so just to put
the transgender stuff to the side for a
second here is the problem for Barack
Obama so the entire left has now made
this case that WikiLeaks is the worst
thing that ever was in the history of
mankind it's terrible terrible terrible
terrible they impacted the election
they've destroyed everything and then
along comes Obama and he says oh yeah
the WikiLeaks guy you know one who's in
jail and endangered American national
security and put American soldiers in
harm's way yeah I'm gonna let him out
so WikiLeaks is okay as long as it
endangers American soldiers but it's not
okay when they're hacking John Podesta
emails about spirit dinners about spirit
cooking right that's when WikiLeaks
becomes bad it exposes the entire
Democratic routine about how terrible
WikiLeaks is when he is releasing the
WikiLeaks guy he's releasing one of the
lead wiki leaks and his excuse for doing
so is really ridiculous he says Manning
is is it feels bad about what Manning
did which is insane watch how long that
lasts in two seconds Manning will be
hired by New York University probably to
lecture about terrorism and war will
become a professor that's it and then
talk of a will be Bill Ayers this is not
a situation where Chelsea man
is somehow really really sorry about
what Chelsea Manning did here that's
that's ridiculous they also said the
Chelsea Manning had served part of his
sentence it was 35 year sentence he
served seven years but really what this
is about in large part was the fact that
Chelsea Manning was transgender so the
left values transgender politics above
all else LGBT politics matter more than
anything else it's literally a get out
of jail free card in this particular
scenario so Chelsea Manning has had some
hormone treatments
I don't believe Chelsea Manning's had
the snip snip but I think Chelsea
Manning's had the hormone treatment and
that means the Chelsea Manning must be
let out of prison West Chelsea Manning
be in a men's prison and be a man who
thinks he's a woman them that would be
absolutely terrible to epsilon select
Chelsea Manning out of prison and this
of course undercuts the entire
Democratic case so they're saying
Trump's illegitimate because of
WikiLeaks but WikiLeaks is so not a
problem that we can release the
WikiLeaks guy
it shows the hypocrisy on the part of
the left now there's hypocrisy on the
right too so the right has determined
that Julian Assange is a hero now Sean
Hannity wants Julian Assange pardoned
Sean had anything Julian Assange is
wonderful now so if Sean Hannity all
that mad about Chelsea Manning being let
out of prison is his Shon head and what
excuse does he have if he is angry the
Chelsea Manning was let out so it's okay
when people are hacking American
institutions like the DNC but bad when
they're revealing secrets about the army
is that the way this works there's a lot
to toss over here and then we have to
get to what what is Barack Obama's
actual true motive in all of this I will
get to that in just a second but first
we have to say thank you to another one
of our advertisers this of course is
ring so if talked about the ring and
security kit and what ring does for me
we use ring at home all the time we have
this put on our front gate and it's
fantastic it means that we can always
check to see who's dropping off a
package we have carroty concerns and
we've had a lot of death threats and
ring helps us deal with that because a
lot of the people who are who are there
to burglarize the house or who are there
to do something nefarious personal
there's a camera on the property a
second of all a lot of them ring the
doorbell to see whether you're home or
not and what ring does it rings to your
phone so you can act like your home or
you can see who's there you have an eye
on your property at all times they also
have an advanced motion detection
technology that comes with the ring of
security kit and it includes a ring
video doorbell for the front door and
ring stick up cam and the
wireless weatherproof HD camera which
keeps an eye on other parts of your
property as I say you know I have a wife
and two kids under three at home and so
I'm definitely interested in security
ring helps me feel secure I bought extra
ring products for my house because I
think that ring is such a good product
go-to rings comm slash bed right now and
if you do you get one hundred and fifty
bucks off your kit which is a pretty
good deal ring comm slash Ben for 150
bucks off your kit it helps prevent home
burglaries it helps ensure that your
property is safe at all times you can
always keep an eye on who's there
ring comm flash Ben for 150 bucks off
your security kit and to thank them for
sponsoring our show okay so I want to
get to President Obama's actual motive
in all of this what does Obama want from
the Chelsea Manning pardon so I think
the Barack Obama is vastly interested in
just undermining the National Defense of
the country I really think that
President Obama does not believe that
the National Defense of the country is
as important as the social justice that
he pursues this is why he's used the
Department of Defense as a sort of
testing ground for various social
justice theories I'm getting all sorts
of the emails by the way from from
soldiers for the last couple of days who
are saying that they're being there
they're being trained on this new
transgender policy put in by President
Obama and it basically says that
soldiers have no right to privacy then
now if you have a man who's in the
female bathroom that all the women just
have to deal with it okay this is Barack
Obama not attempting to make the
military stronger it's Barack Obama
attempting to use the military as a sort
of laboratory experiment for his
politics and he's done this throughout
he doesn't care if he endangered the
national security of the United States
by sending terrorists abroad and
shutting down Gitmo he doesn't care if
he endangers the national security of
our allies in fact one of the other
people that Obama pardoned yesterday one
of the people Obama pardoned yesterday
was the general Cartwright who helped
leaked to the New York Times all the
information about the Stuxnet virus that
Israel in the United States cooperated
on in order to hamper the Iranian
nuclear program upon the pardon that guy
why because Obama hates Israel and he
likes Iran he thinks Iran should be a
regional power
so president's about this all part and
parcel of Obama's dual goal here which
is social justice warrior stuff with the
army which is which makes them the
happiest I mean if the social justice
warriors can take over that repository
of machismo and militarism the US
military then they can take over
anything until Obama takes a little
we in doing that beyond that President
Obama really doesn't care much about the
safety and security of the country he
thinks that safety and security of the
country is achieved through softness he
thinks it's achieved through kindness
and generosity that it's not achieved
through by being the scariest guy on the
block which of course is idiotic but the
left is beginning to realize that what
Obama just it really hurts left Jake
Tapper over on CNN he says this Manning
commutation it really destroys President
Obama's entire line that he cares about
leaks and it also destroys the entire
democratic line the day care about Lakes
commuting the sentence of one of the
most notorious leakers you could argue
that self commanding did it for a good
reason to expose war crimes or whatever
you case you want to make but but it
certainly contradicts the last eight
years of policy in terms of leaking and
it absolutely does of course he's not
the only one the thing this is Bob
Menendez Democrat of New Jersey he's
puzzled by this - because I'm not sure
what message this is supposed to send a
WikiLeaks we're trying to police
WikiLeaks and here you are releasing the
wiki leak or what Russia did as it
relates to our recent elections and the
role that WikiLeaks and the different
iteration has played in that regard
I'm not sure what type of message we
send here and so I'm really surprised
that the president took good action and
not have concerns about what message we
sent about ultimately revealing a
sensitive national security document
again
the Democrats don't know what to do with
President Obama and he doesn't care
about them he only cares about his own
legacy he pleased the far left and CNN's
Jeff Zeleny said he said it's almost
impossible to imagine this commutation
happens in the first place if Chelsea
Manning is just a dude and doesn't and
doesn't believe he's a woman you have to
wonder if the outcome would be the same
I transitioned exactly the energy
transition from a man to a woman I think
that certainly played into this without
side it's hard to imagine I think this
president would have done that
so OJ Simpson is busily attempting to
cut off his own dinghy right now so that
he can earn a commutation from President
Obama at the last minute
if only Julian Assange had decided that
he was a woman and gotten some boob
implants then maybe President Obama
would consider letting him off the hook
as well we have to break here at
Facebook and YouTube but we have much
more coming up about the inauguration we
have a lot more coming up about Vladimir
Putin and about delusional Democrats
and a pretty epic things I hate today so
we'll have to go to daily wired.com to
checked out or to listen later on iTunes
and SoundCloud subscribe at iTunes and
review us at iTunes we know you love us
and make sure that you sender of a 5
star review and over at iTunes if you're
a fan daily wire.com is where you
subscribe $8 a month and for that $8 a
month you not only get to see the rest
of the show live right now right - since
thing you don't have to wait for us to
post it later you also get to be part of
the mailbag tomorrow you also get a free
signed copy of my book true allegiance
and we have some more goodies that are
coming out the Shapiro store is going to
be opening in just the next couple of
weeks and we have other benefits that
are coming as well you see Andrew
Cravens show live in color and his show
is great as well I guess you part of the
mailbag on his show he and I are going
to start launching some some additional
kind of content that we're going to be
putting out for subscribers only to go
to daily wire.com right now and
subscribe we are the largest
conservative podcast in the United
States
you